okay Jonathan let's start with you
quarantine hair is a thing a lot of
people have really wild hair right now
so what would you say is the number one
mistake people are making when it comes
to doing their own hair I think doing
too much like just going in for like too
much of an at-home hair cut too much of
an at-home hair color I mean it is so
difficult to like fix something that you
like really win SuperDuper sure you
really really bleep dare you really
really win like just any huge big
dramatic changes that you're gonna have
to commit to I think that would probably
be the biggest thing because ain't
nobody got time to go to the salon and
spend all that money to get the
correction that's you know I think yeah
I'm all about I would tell people to err
on the side of caution
nice crime oh I feel like you guys work
with such a variety of people and we see
how much you change their lives but I
wanna know how much people change your
lives and you're working with them in
each of their stories oh my gosh every
single person we work with changes my
life and I think all of us is part of
the five five because when you hear
someone else's story you learn empathy
you educate yourself on their experience
and with that empathy of that education
is when you start to be able to walk in
the world and be a true ally to amplify
their story and their voice and you know
like right now in the world that's what
we're seeing people are waking up and
hearing other people's stories and
they're educating themselves or having
empathy and they're going out there and
they're protesting amplifying you know
African American voices the voices of
trans people it's just a beautiful
moment right now and and so I learn
every single time it's the greatest gift
of being a queer I outside of knowing
these four knuckleheads that you know I
say knuckleheads of love is that you
know literally learning so much about
other people well a really nice part to
that this season was getting introduced
to Walter the dog Antony how fun was it
having Walter in the house we loved well
obviously I welcome all dogs of all
colors shapes sizes and temperaments but
Walter was was a sweetie he did scare
ten a little bit ten yeah
I was the one that would touch I was
scared of Walter mean qualms in like
little dogs you guys aren't intimidated
by but as soon as they reach like a
certain height you guys get like a
little uncomfortable that's why both of
my babies are tiny Walter Walter is a
sweetheart he's a little wackadoodle has
like the the face of like some like old
shipment from like 1400s yet he's very
much like a puppy yeah and I like his
Instagram so far pretty good he's very
much yeah um how much did you guys like
working in Philadelphia and how much do
you feel like that location really
impacted this show for this season I
loved Philadelphia um I loved it I think
it's such a um it's a really important
history or a city I never got to live in
it as far as American history is
concerned and while living there I
really got to learn so much about the
city's history and getting to sightsee
and go to museums and having the
exposure to those museums and some of
those early American iconic places like
just got me to have a lot more
conversations with myself and get a lot
more curious about a lot of stuff that I
think is was a really frankly good and
eye-opening conversations for me to have
with myself when I was there promo you
were a shirt that did be kind to
yourself in the first episode so what
are some ways that you think people can
be kind to themselves especially during
this way well I think the first thing to
do is uh not to compare yourself to what
anybody else is doing
that's a big thing I mean when
Quarantine started I mean like I was one
of those people who I was like where's
everybody getting this energy from to do
tick-tocks to dance to do everything
because I was in my sweats every day and
so you have to go to that place of being
like you know what it's okay if I'm
needing time to process what's happening
in the world a little differently or a
little bit longer than someone else and
then in the morning time when you wake
up before you do anything you know I try
to practice before I pick up my phone I
go onto the
I wash my face brush my teeth and
instead of focusing on something that I
don't like about myself try to focus on
something I do and I just starts your
day off with the intention of loving
yourself and being kind here so rather
than going on to the world and seeing
what everyone else is doing and focusing
on the rest of the world start here
first so that you can be better out in
the world